what's up guys is asking helping
GameSpot and I am here with Michael and
Miguel we're here at e3 2017 and last
night we went to see a buncha games at
Sony's booth and I'm gonna kick it off
with Miguel you saw Detroit become human
yes I mean I was going into it already
being um having played a lot of David
cages games and it seems like it's
there's always been this element of like
technology technology in his games but
it seems to be like the focal point this
time especially the fact that you know
the characters are our androids and it
almost makes me reminds her like what
David Kate had played a lot of like date
sex it looked pretty slow from what we
saw the conference right right it looked
very similar to its previous stuff heavy
rain it's almost like he's like doubling
down on sort of like that babycakes yes
style did you enjoy it though I enjoyed
it in the sense that I mean I'm
intrigued to learn more intrigued to see
how like the overall story plays
especially when you're using nurture
playing as different characters and we
we saw the trailer featuring Jesse
Williams that itself was very intriguing
also well next on the list Michael you
and I played a bit 505 which basically
looked like folk rock right again so we
played that same sequence that we saw at
the was it that Ubisoft or conference so
it was it was fun to actually jump in
and be there and experience it for
myself yeah but I asked if it was on a
ps4 or ps4 Pro because the performance
was pretty lacking it was not good but
uh you know the game stood it's still in
an early stage and it's coming out next
year so I wouldn't expect it to be fully
optimized but I played it in a full
full-on firefight so a lot of things
were happening a lot of things were
exploding shooting calling in the Nick
Rhys air strikes which is really cool
oh yeah you played with that guy yeah
that was three buddies available to play
so that was that guy who dropped bombs
and was like he was like the action hero
right and then there was a dog which is
like stealth option
there was a sniper option as well which
I saw being played in front of me but I
picked the dog I find it quite difficult
to actually play in stealth I didn't
feel like there were many opportunities
to isolate characters to take my one by
one so I ended up just having to go
allows the dog still helps you in that
situation as well
Miguel you played ninokuni too right yes
and so did Mike yeah I always played it
right so um I came into it really having
a been a big fan of the original neo
Connect it's interesting just watching
this game with this studio ghibli art
style running at 60 frames per second
because now we're used to seeing it the
freedom a cinematic way the one thing
that I think will be pretty the visit
will be the switch from sort of what we
call the Pokemon of the comments from
the previous game and now it's sort of
styled and themed like pigment pigment
yeah and all higgledy-piggledy ZZZ yeah
Haegele DS and the I mean I mean not to
knock them I mean they're super helpful
in battle and it just sort speaks to the
faster pace of this game I mean it feels
more like an action RPG than the
previous one yeah there's a story wise
it's going to be a separate from what we
saw and you know could be one but it
takes place in the same universe you'll
be playing as King Evan is his name he's
a he's a king at being dong Bell yo so
happy to be back and I'm just happy to
be back in that sort of the universe as
well where that art style and another 50
60 hundred hour RPG on ps4 I'm ready to
go man
I believe Joey Sashi is doing the sound
trick again yes yeah
awesome he's the Miyazaki got it all
yeah sweet awesome well next up we all
checked out for my Gran Turismo sport at
the event they had like this awesome
racing chair set up but at the same time
it's just when Turismo on ps4 yeah how
did you place ten thirds well that's
pretty good means that last yeah I mean
it's not last that's what I aim for a
life right it's a not be last
but yeah you to have both played the
recent veto right yeah is there anything
to it other than just Gran Turismo on
Pierce cool so far I feel like it's just
you know it's
I love Gran Turismo since day one so I'm
excited just have it on ps4 I did check
out the PSP our support right which was
essentially you know you're in the
cockpit you can look around and drive
stuff and stuff like that now that was
cool so that's a neat addition it was
interesting how they didn't put that in
that conference as well they put that in
a pre-show oh yeah it's it's sort of a
known quantity Gran Turismo sport but uh
I'm gonna play it because you know I'm
all about that he's one of our
best-selling drivers I can t beat
templates well hello low bar to clear
here at game sponsor and the last game
we played Michael you might check tight
knack to yo Geoffrey excited about yeah
what did you think of it well thanks for
getting my back in that game cuz we're
doing that co-op stuff we were doing a
more combat centric sequence yeah and I
mean it was there's a lot of fun you
should jump in you started like smashing
things and like fighting enemies and
stuff so we were talking to one of the
devs about how much depth there is
because you can essentially go into the
game like mash buttons and still enjoy
what it has to offer
but he also explained that there's going
to be several things within a skill tree
that you can do and we are also
discovering on our own like co-op
abilities where I would like jump up and
like smash on you and then like you
would have like a but your parts like
fly out and damage enemies yeah so I
think I think that you know one of the
more exciting parts is like seeing what
you can do with that within the
yeah there was this move where you can
basically like punch through the other
character yes I was basically just
annoying you by punching you in yeah and
stuff yeah hey but it was it was clutch
for when we were fighting or we were
trying to avoid those boulders coming
down on us yeah he like punched through
me and like projected and destroyed the
boulders in our way yeah so you know we
only got a small slice of it but I also
asked how much variation there's gonna
there's gonna be because they also
mentioned that it's about a 10 to 12
hour campaign so you know I want to see
different styles of environments
different challenges along the way and I
suppose we'd have to wait so we got our
hands on Mac - yeah definitely I think
it's got a lot of points price point as
well which is really interesting
was it 40 bucks 40 bucks yeah so that is
pretty much everything we played at
Sony's e3 booth stay tuned to game sport
for all the latest news so you can get
the game spot now up as well if you want
to get that and until then we'll see you
next time
[Music]
you